we've been talking about stationary
points right and determining their
nature but you've noticed that
stationary points and turning points
they overlap like big-time like well
turning points are all going to be
stationary points right but not all
stationary points are the turning points
so this difference even though it's
subtle is the one I'm going to focus on
to help you understand points of
reflection okay so here talking about
points of inflection
the best way to understand a point of
inflection and to make sure you don't
get confused about it is to think of
them like turning points not like
stationary point you're like unstable
the same thing answers
oh not quite right what is a turning
point let's actually write this down you
have a picture in your head of what a
turning point is I want to give you
words for it now not just a picture okay
because sometimes this is actually
instructive for us a turning point is
where the gradient goes from negative to
positive or from positive to negative
okay let me say that again
a turning point that guy or that guy is
where the gradient changes sign from
negative let's go green gradient from
negative to positive or positive to
negative a turning point is the point
where to the left to the right the sign
of the gradient has changed so a turning
point marks a change in the sign of the
gradient now the reason why this is
important because now that opens up the
definition of your or them the two
features are just true okay we are just
defining turning points by letting the
stationary like finding stationary point
first and the same some of your
stationary points may or may not be
turning points but you already know a
graph we had a look at it just last week
that has a turning point unit that is
not a stationary point okay it has a
turning point because the gradient
changes sign something you're very
familiar with do you remember yeah so
this function here right admittedly it's
a piecemeal so it kind of breaks it a
little bit but that doesn't matter
it's a turning point because there's a
change in the sign of the gradient right
you have a look you can see oh I'm
increasing and increasing now at that
point there at the origin is not a
stationary point we've talked about this
before why is it not a stationary point
yeah that's right like to be a
stationary point you need to do to be
zero I don't even have a derivative at
that point let alone interpretive that's
zero okay my stationary point but it is
a turning point when you think about
this definition of things and this is
the definition it it will it turns you
see that it turns around okay
now points inflection I just like this
but therefore like that for concavity
rather than gradient okay so let's write
this out a point of inflection it marks
a change in the sign of the Concannon
now this is really really helpful right
because now you see right if I were to
find Y points of inflection ah and
that's what the next question asked me
find the coordinates of any points of
inflection how do I find these well you
would normally think just like see how I
do this way right
I found stationary points by saying well
F - or equal zero okay and that's fine
but that's not the only way to get a
turning point right and in exactly the
same way finding where the second
derivative is zero right just letting
that equals here that's not the only way
to find a point of inflection okay so
you have to be a little bit careful you
can have discontinuities on the left and
right sorry just come to news at a point
and the concavity changes on the left
and right and I'm going to give you
proper examples of that in a second okay
so now that you have this you can see
because there has to be a change in the
sign right hmm to find a point of
inflection
you're like woohoo I have a second dude
now I'm free of having to use a table of
values on now after the table of values
again except you will have to use a
change of values because if you need a
change inside you've got a go before and
you've got to go after there's no use
telling me what's happening there
right at that point I want the change I
need to go negative positive or positive
negative okay yes yes they just give you
a picture yeah so the thing is right
with that once you get if you get a
picture right the picture is all you
need because the picture will tell you
comprehensively like
okay so no I'm not quite you want to
have a look and I literally don't like
this I've run out of my papers here we
go this office you just have to do did I
write this no actually this will be a
buddy okay so for example you have a
look at this now admittedly this is a
rather low tech way of doing it but it
works okay if I want to find where is it
that the concavity changes okay
I'm again I'm thinking about like is the
cup up or does it come down okay so when
I have a look for example I don't cover
up some part of the graph okay so for
example this part here that's clearly
concave down isn't it really okay and
you can go past you go like to a certain
point you're like wait a second it's
time to wiggle back up right like you
get to wait a lot of going too far right
and then you come back no I've narrowed
it okay now that's much easier than
trying to look at it like that and say
it's there okay you you can't see it as
easily whereas when you cover it you
like I can see a change very very
dramatically okay so that's what I
actually recommend use okay so I can
I'll just show you really quickly we're
all the points inflection are on this
guy okay so um
greenies gradients I'm gonna use red I
don't have a color that's not specific
so these are all concave down here is
that okay okay here you can see this is
concave up up up up okay now about it
you can see I've got to get to a maximum
and a maximum is concave down right so
at some point in here it's going to
change I would have to guess that it's
somewhere about there okay so now you
say okay concave down down oh yeah
absolutely
like I don't have I don't have actual
values because I don't
function for this thing I hope I'm glad
I never function for this thing that was
the thunder disaster okay
so you can see I am having to
approximate but you usually get like a
much larger graph we would talk about
this an interestin actually and you'll
be able to make pretty safe like is in
they say oh here you go told me what's
happening there you know within within
reason yes
like if it's motivation every point is a
good chance that it's a point so you can
see you don't for very long because you
can see I'm already approaching on the
maximum maybe that's fall right there
that's that's a badly drawn graph but
but if I had to make a conclusion about
it whose phone came up to me is a very
is a very simple way of thinking about
it right if I wish again I didn't bring
it with me if I were to get a um some
water right and pour it on here I can
pour all over the whole graph okay where
was the water rest now the water is
going to it's going to rest in some
spots and it's gonna roll off in other
spots
okay so for example like if I want to
put a drop of water right there just a
drop okay where is it going to go
well it's really going to it's gonna
roll down this way right but is it like
how quickly you can draw ladies are
gonna roll fast isn't gonna slow down as
we're always gonna increase so what are
the key
so that means it's a minimum changing
can cavity that's changing gradients
going use when you said going down and
going up that's a change in gradient
that's not a change in concavity
this whole thing is concave up there's
no change in the sign in the signing of
the concavity okay so it's up up up up
that's why I draw arrows indicate
concavity so that I'm confusing with
gradient which I draw as plus as a movie
okay so